has there has there been any other time
that you can think of where the the
older generations sacrificed the young
for their safety we have this story from
timcast.com teen facing two years in
prison for violating covet rules in
australia the 19 year old teen was
arrested after visiting a nightclub in
south australia following a positive
covid19 test now i want to be real with
everybody kind of a dick move all right
when we all got coveted here we said
everybody if you're not sick work you
know work remotely we don't want you to
get sick and for the people who are sick
when you're better like you know
unlimited sick time just do your work do
what you can hang out play video games
have a good time consider a vacation i
hope you get better we um i think
anyone eligible for the treatment uh
here ended up getting it some people who
were sick weren't here and didn't get it
and then i said before you come back i
want you to feel better and take a test
we'll get you a test it's a it's a
little it's a it's you know i don't know
what are they 20 bucks we're not going
to mandate them forever we're only
asking you to do this because you are
sick right now and if you're still sick
until testing positive yo just stay home
we're not going to stop paying you we're
like do your thing
for this teen
to know he's sick and be like i'm going
to go out anyway dick move but prison
for this right it feels like there are
scared older people who are the most
susceptible and i can respect that
they're scared but to
let me stop right now
fukushima
when the reactor went off or broke and
melted down and the radiation spewing
all over luke and i actually went there
we actually went and and filmed various
stories and many docs about this the
elderly
decided they would go into the reactor
to shut to try and stop it and clean it
up knowing it would kill them because
they said we've lived our lives and we
must do this for the young and i'm just
like man think about that
these are people who are like i've lived
my life now i'm going to die to save the
next generation
what we have here in europe and the west
in the united states is the inversion of
that it's older people who are like i
don't want to get sick tell them to stay
in their cubicles and take away their
jobs and their income and their
resources and give the money to walmart
it's remarkable that is cultural decay
to a point where i don't i don't see us
surviving
it's um
to me the way that i've perceived this
personally is like
say the right wing is pro-gun and then
you had a locus infestation and there's
locus everywhere and then the right wing
is like yes and then everyone has to
have a gun now you have to have a gun
and you have to have a gun and you have
to have a gun if you everyone needs a
gun shoot the locust right and you're
like you don't really need a gun to
shoot the loch's like yes you do you're
not going to defend us we'll all die if
you don't have a gun
to me this is the ultimate wish list for
people who like to strip rights it's
just it's like the perfect situation it
doesn't mean that a lot of things they
say aren't accurate i think a lot of it
is accurate but it is a perfect dream
it's the perfect situation it provides
the perfect justification and so
here's here's my favorite part it would
the extension of this this logic would
be like if people that are more
self-responsible came along and they
said
i've worked to become someone who
doesn't get triggered and i'm not
sensitive i'm unoffendable because you
you can actually work on that that's a
real thing you can i teach this i do it
you can really really work to be
unoffended right yeah you could just
like i will teach this will sound crazy
but i'll teach courses where like i'll
have all my students put me in a circle
and just start yelling insults at me
and i just have to sit there and i have
to deal with it and then i'll get them
to go in a circle and then you realize
they're like why do i care about words
this doesn't matter at all you can
easily get out this you build your
confidence if you're not so much in your
ego if you view it as a joke you don't
take it so personally you can actively
work on that right so what if people who
had worked on that were to say um you
know it's illegal for you to be offended
or let's say somebody who worked on
their health said it's illegal for you
not to be healthy which is kind of what
they do with the drug word i don't
believe in that or what if somebody
who's worked to become wealthy said if
you let yourself go broke
that's illegal because it's going to
cause a problem for me or what if
somebody who's worked on critical
thinking and how to look at multiple
different arguments or misinformation
and learns how to not be affected by
that or influenced by that and then i
said if you're naive there's a mandate
against being naive right so what
they've done is they've ex they've used
that kind of logic
um to create a situation that frankly
i mean you're going to have most
freedom-oriented people moving to texas
moving to florida into wyoming but if
you've ever read the second book in the
bible exodus it's beginning to look like
exodus where people are like i don't
want to be a part of the satanic system
i want to get out of here i'm moving to
where people are free and tim i think
you were one of the people who first
brought this up or you said there could
be parallel economies i mean things get
pretty crazy if they keep doing this
they're they're already pretty crazy and
uh i just wanted to point out i would
use my flamethrower on the locus i think
that's more of a reasonable thing to do
but sorry tim you were saying something
no yes parallel economies yeah so you've
already you're already seeing it there
was a news article about dan bongino
that they were smearing him he's got one
of the biggest podcasts in the world but
oh he's he's uh uh he's an investor in
and he utilizes specific technology
companies and financial companies that
won't ban him
and they're mad about it the the media
matters guy was like it used to just be
that if there was a right winger you
could just call up your friends the
company and they'd ban them it's not
literally what he said but you know you
get my point he's like no we can't
okay that's a problem not it's not a
problem that you that the right has
found a new a new path towards you know
being able to speak and and flourish the
problem is that you abused your
positions
and created this fracture that's the
problem we don't want this country
divided we want this country united but
when you have ideologues cultists
and they're doing this they're abusing
people they're taking away people's
livelihoods like patreon did i'm
surprised people still use patreon
because the risk to your life i'll tell
you this patreon banned two people
without warning taking away all of their
income
this is several years ago and it led to
an exodus and there are still people i
talk to i'm like like there are people i
know people have had on the show like
i'm on patreon i'm like why
they they'll they will not give you a
warning before they take your income
away get off patreon
i mean look there there's issues we've
criticized locals but locals is still
better than patreon yeah and this is
what they do also in china if you
violate the law if you jaywalk they
automatically with facial recognition
take a photo of you and deduct money out
of your bank account in australia
they're also going after people's bank
accounts
as in october they collected 5.2 million
dollars in fines for covet violations
they seized people's homes they seized
their bank accounts they took away their
business licenses for not following
decree so i think even with the
financial system that we have right now
a lot of people are seeing its
weaknesses a lot of people are seeing
how fragile it is and a lot of people
are seeing what kind of a con game it
really is and that parallel kind of
economy is already happening and i think
it's happening with crypto and i think
it's pretty evident with a lot of people
saying i trust this random
boop coin rather than of course the us
dollar and i think that's becoming more
prevalent by the day because the us
dollar is becoming more of a joke than
boob coin and um it's only a matter of
time until these parallel economies are
conflicted with each other and
i want people to understand something
too youtube it's it's really fascinating
youtube has one of the lowest um what i
don't know what the right word is for
it's not necessarily cpm
but i think it was ti who posted this
he said here's how many streams of a
song you'll need to get to earn one
dollar on these platforms and on youtube
it was like 1 250
streams to get one dollar on napster it
was like 53. people need to understand
this there's a lot of people who are on
youtube we're on youtube but we
understand and i've understood this for
a long time youtube is actually a very
low value incentive for podcasts and for
businesses this is why
so many people don't care this is why
joe rogan only puts clips up on on
youtube he's on spotify he knows
podcast platforms substantially more
valuable they reach regular people
youtube meets uh reaches for the most
part people who are in the weeds who are
very politically affiliated now youtube
is extremely valuable i'm not saying
it's not valuable at all i'm just saying
it's one of the least valuable platforms
what youtube does offer up is free
marketing and they know it so for us
this is why early in the year we were
like we need to make a website we need
to we need to start doing news we need
to stop relying on mainstream news
sources and that's why we're heavily
focused on memberships and not just
youtube oh my god i think boopcoin is an
actual real coin i'm not here giving you
any financial advice i literally just
made up two words out of my mind i'm not
here telling you to invest in boopcoin
i'm seeing the comments they're like
coin's real bootcamp store you should
this is the i'm like no no no no no not
telling you guys what to do here
don't know anything about boob coin i
literally just made it up i need to
learn more about being more financially
responsible please so here's a couple
challenges that i've seen with what
you're talking about here so one so one
of the challenges that i've seen is that
as soon as somebody would create an
alternate platform um the type of people
that most people wouldn't want to be
associated with will initially flock
there so that creates an initial
branding right and then you've got and
so there's there's this
kind of messed up argument that people
don't get in my view which is this say
that i say to you right now are you
pro-crime right you're going to answer
no i'm not pro-crime well actually
yeah okay so
look i'll
if you were if you were in like a it was
a political debate between left and
right and a right-wing person was like
are you pro-crime they would be like
what is that supposed to mean like yeah
there would be no straight answer okay
so let's say that hypothetically you're
saying no i'm not pro-crime so say that
i say to you okay well if you're not pro
crime then what i'm going to do is on
every single street corner i'm going to
put somebody there who's going to frisk
you every single street corner that you
go to there's going to be somebody there
and you know they're going to start you
know they're going to go in who knows
what place to frisk you right full body
cavity search yes full body cavity
search and by the way if you don't want
the full body cavity search you are pro
crime and then you say i'm not pro crime
uh i just want the full body cavity
search and they say what are you going
to say to that person who had a crime
conflicted against them because you
would not allow the full-bodied cabbage
is you not wanting to have your cavity
search at each corner worth it for what
happened to little jimmy over here
what are you going to say to little
jimmy who was affected if they would
have gotten a full body cap do you
support antifa
no so you're so you're pro fascist
that's literally what they do yeah and
you're like no yeah but antifa literally
killed people but so they're rioting so
the media works works on optics it works
well actually individuals yeah so if
you're so if you're trying to be pro
full body cavity search on every single
corner all that you need to do is find
five or ten really really horrific
crimes and say look what happened a
little jimmy and little jimmy's like i
just want the cavity search and it's
like do you care about little jimmy
right and they can keep doing that again
and again but it doesn't mean that
you're a pro criminal it just means that
the the the cure is worse than just we
got it we got it we got man we need to
get i was talking to sheamus from frame
tunes about like comedy writing and
doing some some bits and that would be a
really great bit where it's like an
infomercial like last year little jimmy
was attacked on the street because
there were no body cavity searches on
street corners just like really extreme
security state stuff and then you get
like a crying kid and it plays like
sarah mclachlan or whatever so so if
you're a business um and this is one
when i think one of the challenges with
you know the typical american
individualism right where in america we
say you know you kind of handle your own
i mean what we're you know back in the
day we would have said you handle your
thing i'll handle my thing so what you
have is that you have on one side you
have collectivism on the other side you
have individualism right so if you're
running a business and then you see
another if you you see that another
business was impacted by this whole
little jimmy phenomenon you could say
hey that's bs i don't support that this
guy is not pro crime he just he just
doesn't want body cavity searches but if
you're running your business you just
kind of keep your head down and you
don't say anything so in collectivism
they'll all stick up for each other but
in individualism there's less of that so
as a result they will stick up for each
other very very quickly even individuals
won't even when
um depending on your source it's like 26
to 36 dead in the george floyd riots
they will unabashedly unashamed
they will bail these people out they
have uh their allies in positions of
power will support it without question
and then you look at the republicans the
republicans are like one of our members
of congress at a naughty word so we've
stripped them of all committee and
booted them from the party and then ill
and omar is like i'm just gonna keep
talking to the democrats who are like we
literally will do nothing we will
literally do nothing and then the funny
thing is because these people don't read
the news the democrats just claim it's
actually the republicans doing it and
they believe it
there you go antifa can go around
smashing windows beating minorities
screaming racial slurs in portland which
i've personally witnessed and it has
been reported numerous times
and the left will defend them tooth and
nail
they literally have people getting on
their knees for them in support there's
a lot there's a lot of other psychology
you were talking about
oh and uh that got my attention let me
let me play the video let me i'm gonna
it's an old video i've posted before i
posted it again the more followers i get
the more i want to keep playing this
video here you go
is there is there audio for this ism
anti-blackness or violence
racism
i will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
[Music]
let me explain for those that are not
watching and can only hear
it all
thousands of people sitting down with
their hands in the air as the the
preacher of of social justice
makes a statement and everyone just like
drones i will use my voice this is a
cult now if you want to complain about
trump supporters all act worshiping the
you know trump in the ground he walks on
yes but that's the exception not the
rule that is few and far between there
are people who are like that but that's
not the majority of people who are
libertarian moderate or even voted for
trump a lot of people who voted for
trump don't like the guy but they hate
the establishment and they don't want to
be in your cult
so what happens when you don't feel safe
within yourself is that your mind will
not allow you to think beyond which
opinions allow you to feel more safe so
you know for example like one of the
reasons why things like christianity or
religion are actually very powerful is
that if you believe that you have a life
beyond the body that allows you to open
your mind to a range of different
thoughts because you're not because
you're not as afraid of getting killed
you feel there's something beyond this
right but even just basic level
confidence allows you to think beyond
what you're just supposed to pipe back
so this concept of say some people call
it virtue signaling is this idea that
you know for some people if they don't
feel safe their mind is not scanning
saying is this accurate can i find
statistics on this can i even question
those statistics can i look at multiple
sources their mind is going to what will
get me props when i say this and so i
think to
to improve this problem of people that
will say
just do whatever gets them props in the
crowd you can remember back to being
back in grade school some of the trends
that were popular and how the kids would
just try to jump into like i'm cool now
right is this cool is that cool and kids
would even beat up other friends like
because they weren't popular anymore
things like that and the cool thing
about being an adult was when you
finally get to get away from that you're
like i don't have to be cool in high
school anymore i could just say what i
really think but now society's evolving
to where it's bringing it back to that
where you have to be hyper aware of what
what the hive mind is thinking and if
you say something outside of that it can
cost you your career it can cost you
your life i mean
it's totally crazy so i think that
i i had i had a moment like this in
berkeley during the riots in like 2018
where i have i had a gopro and a gimbal
so i'm walking around with this you know
little thing i'm filming what's going on
there's police and i'm talking to
someone when all of a sudden this woman
starts talking to me so that's arguing
not like a fierce argument but she hears
what i'm saying she hears what i'm
talking about and then immediately you
know starts to interject so i turn to
this woman on a public street
and she's talking so i asked her
questions
there was a woman who was attacked by
antifa and left bloody why well she was
wearing something that was conservative
and so this woman told me well maybe she
shouldn't wear that in an area where she
knows someone might get mad about it and
i said so you think it's her fault for
wearing the wrong clothes and that you
know she should have worn something
different she wouldn't have gotten
attacked and she goes yes and i was like
so you think it was the victim's fault
she's like yeah and then i was like okay
well thank you for your time then after
about a minute she runs back over me she
goes no no don't use any of that don't
use anything
and i was like you walked up to me and
started talking and she's like you're
not allowed to use that footage
i feel the reason she did that was
because she had real opinions real
opinions that a lot of people have like
yo if you stuff your wallet if you go to
an atm and pull out a thousand bucks and
then walk into dark alley whistling
about how you got money and you get
robbed people are gonna be like why were
you doing that
it's a bummer you got robbed the
burglars are they're not the robbers are
the criminals but that was kind of dumb
regular people would say that but the
modern left is like don't blame the
victim when it hap well this woman
genuinely felt there is some
responsibility to be safe and to
understand what you're getting yourself
into but when she realized it went
against the mob and the cult then she
was like delete it don't use it i
blurred her face because i don't think
she matters as a public figure i put the
video up i blurred her face because i
thought what the person was saying and
and the ideology of the person was more
important and i don't want to cause any
conflict for the individual but people
needed to hear all of that including her
her attempts to recant and say no no no
i i don't i don't like that they're
scared of the mob they're scared of
their own political ideology thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you